jean yanne lui est un camelot assez peu
ordinaire il s'est installé sur les
boulevards
il sévit en tête de vendre des bijoux
mais alors des bijoux à un prix
franchement exorbitants seulement
va-t-il y parvenir
là est la question aux journées moselle
et moselle où le nouveau procès si vous
aimez les beaux bijoux de les voir
exceptionnellement le comité de la
joaillerie française pour les deux
nouvel an représentent ces articles
réclame alors nous avons ici un lot
voyez vous un bracelet en cuir et
brillant valeur si milan 4 un bracelet
brillant et rubis valeur 7 millions nous
avons ici quatre clips d'un million
chacun 1 2 3 4 millions et le collier de
perles en plus c'est bien tout ça si
vous le voulez grâce à la vente réclame
du comité de la joaillerie française
voulant porter pour combien
pas pour un million façon 19 contre 18 4
17 pas pour 16 millions mais pour 15
milliards selon c'était la ferme et une
passe et une affaire que ça vous
intéresse
15 millions seulement quand les pêcheurs
santé mais pas les tories masure mais
bon les constructeurs gardent et c'est
une bonne qualité ces ventes
exceptionnelles n'y en aura pas pour
tout le monde y est de l'eau jambes
quand fillon monsieur ça vous intéresse
vente exceptionnelle du comité de la
jarrie bancaire continue et si vous
tentez monsieur je sais que ce après
plusieurs échanges de cadeaux et le
cabrio
cela représente autorités de la jeanne
les français nous vendent des bijoux qui
sera les faux bijoux s'est pas présenté
la première fois qu'on fait souvent
passer plus nos galères 7 millions de la
platé pour la moitié
mais lequel personne je vais faire
quelque chose pour vous dire écoutez
voila j'aimerais ajouter un petit bras
c'est un type intelligent de monsieur je
vous parle a toujours vers l'achat vous
me barrer s'il vous plaît vous vivez
vous le fait alors du comité de
l'algérie française des jeux vous nous
présentez vous préparez votre petit peu
tiède